Kirk gray and I'm Chris Bray and we're
with the leaker historically with our
company we were influenced by a few
different people are dead at a lot of
influence on us and then another guy
named Arnold errands who is a
third-generation leather maker in LA we
use the military Western Americana horse
tack as not necessarily a base for where
we get a lot of our bridges cuz it was
made well I think about the tool bag we
called Nova cariño we were using these
bags to literally carried samples and
tools how can we make this so make one
could take it as a weekender you know up
north whatever and we just sort of hit
on it because we used it and now they
are everywhere one of the guys that we
renew back there's war two veteran who
was a leather guy he was selling his
stuff up and down the coast we ended up
getting a bunch of his cutting dies
these are the wide cuffs the originals
that whole era is fascinating you know
if I ever see these old photos back
there you see a guy with a wide cuff
it's just it's just cool
you